welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we're taking your calls at eight
from five to three 6:30 to 28 that's
eight five five two three six thirty to
twenty eight crystal in California
you're on the bench piercer I'll go from
crystal
hi mr. Shapiro thanks for taking my call
I had a question in regard to what Trump
was saying yesterday he indicated that
he has total authority over um when the
states reopen but he also mentioned that
he would work with governments with with
the governors of those particular states
is that constitutional or would that be
under the emergency order that may
possibly be in place I just wanted some
clarification on that yeah so the
president doesn't in the emergency order
that's in place really allows the
federal government to mobilize resources
it doesn't really allow the President to
lock down particular areas of the
country it's been governors that I've
been locking down particularly Ria's of
the country which is why it was the
president who announced sort of the
15-day guidelines which became 30-day
guidelines on social distancing and
staying at home that was much more
federal recommendation than a federal
mandate which is why they're still
states that have not issued stay at home
orders right the state of Texas is not
issued a stay at home order statewide
for example that's because the federal
government really does not have the
power to enforce anything like that you
know unless you have basically Congress
step in and give him those sorts of
powers so the president does not
actually have tremendous national
emergency power this has been one of the
problems for the media one of the
problems for the media is that they've
been lying about this all along they've
been suggesting that the federal
government has the tremendous power to
issue some sort of national lockdown
order the federal government does not
have the power to do that we have a
federalist system we should have a
federalist system Texas should not be
treated like New York City in fact
virtually no place in the United States
should be treated like New York City
we've had in the United States
approximately 22,000 deaths 10,000 of
those deaths so far have occurred in New
York State alone and the vast majority
of those deaths have occurred in New
York City why because people are living
right on top of each other and so areas
of the country where people are not
living on top of each other which is to
say 95% of the country in a territorial
way you know why would you lock down in
exactly the same way at the same time
the minute that Trump says I want to
take control this thing then the media
are like how dare he try to take control
of this thing so Trump's being
inconsistent but the media are being
just as inconsistent you can count on it
every single time the minute Trump flips
on a dime
every single person in the media flips
on a time - so they go from Trump should
take national control - how dared from
suggest he's gonna take national control
he doesn't have the power to do that
so federalism yesterday was their enemy
now federalism is their friend weird how
that works
correct that I agree with you but he was
actually saying that he wants to reopen
them and he can reopen those states
based on his presidency so my
understanding of the Constitution is
that no he can't actually enact that it
would have to be the states that was
reopens right he he he cannot force a
state to reopen its own home right he he
could theoretically theoretically you
could have some sort of lawsuit against
a state and then it gets taken to the
Supreme Court for example for violating
federal civil rights but I think that
that would be let very likely to fail
the federal government does not have the
power to do that barring for example
let's say that they suspend elections
and and now they have a non republican
form of government then the federal
government can step in if you lose the
right to vote the federal government has
the power to step in but very
restrictive ability for the federal
government to step in at a time of
emergency and say no no you got to
reopen your state by the way I don't
think that that's Trump's job I don't
think that's the president's job if
you're if you're Andrew Cuomo you have
very different priorities then if you
are governor Newsom in California your
state has been hit in California we've
had seven hundred deaths in New York
I've had ten thousand right California
has a population of 50 million so that
is the or 40 million so obviously the
state this is like a perfect example of
why federalism exists and is useful and
the bizarre notion that the federal
government should take it over in the
first place either to issue like a
widespread everybody go back to work
order or a widespread lockdown order is
patently silly crystal ranked correct I
agree and I also agree with you and
saying that New York has something more
cases because they're so heavily
populated people take transit so you
have a lot of just germ circulating
within the air and you know they're not
also being proactive and being clean and
cleaning the streets and and doing what
they can to prevent the virus from
spreading I feeling yes I mean that's
right imagine the Newton New York is a
unique center for this sort of stuff
everybody travels via public
transportation you are literally in a
small you're in an airplane every single
day right breathing
all the same as other people within five
inches of each other you work in office
buildings where you're five feet away
from somebody else you live in apartment
buildings there is no sky in New York
City
the reason la has escaped this I am
firmly convinced is because we're
suburban everybody lives outside of the
the urban areas in LA there's not that
many people in heavily populated areas
so that is the you know that is sort of
the situation again I think that it is
it is you know silly for anybody to
attempt a national control system over a
diverse country the way this is crystal
really appreciate the call
Lindsey in Michigan you're on the bench
parish I go for Lindsey hi then I was
wondering would you ever run for a form
of office that sounds awful it sounds
terrible
having to be on the road that much and
then having to be in government with
people who are in government sounds
quite terrible you know only if
situations sort of forced it upon me
would I would I be even remotely
interested in something like that when I
was younger I was much more interested
in now I basically have the dream job I
get to say what I think and I don't have
to worry about the electoral
consequences Wednesday to say thank you
I appreciate the call I appreciate you
listening to the show clay on line five
here on the bench up your elbow for clay
how do you then my question for you and
it's kind of an odd premise question
because clearly these are two very
different events but my question was
about what do you think is worse overall
and clearly we don't know the long
lasting effects of the coronavirus yet
but overall on the United States you
know morally I mean the coronavirus was
killed so far like 24,000 people but
what do you think is worse 911 for the
United States or the coronavirus clearly
coronavirus has killed a lot more people
so far but I believe that 911 as a whole
was you know a fairly jarring event for
the United States well I mean you know
honestly what was you know worse to
experience in the moment probably 911 in
the moment but what is worse to
experience over a long haul there's no
question that this is much worse like
much much worse I was here for both and
this is a completely different thing in
kind it's like telling people to stay in
their house for months on end telling
people if they go outside they could die
telling people they can never go back to
work telling people that it's a sin
to even discuss going back to work
suggesting to people that the federal
government ought to pay your salary from
now till the end of time and that we
ought to fundamentally reshift how we
think about the nature of government
itself like yeah this is way worse this
is way worse and just in terms of the
toll that it's taking on the American
people I think it is way worse
at least there you have an external
enemy there was a moment of unity where
everybody went oh those bastards want to
kill us let's go over there and let's
let's kick their asses like that that I
think was a lot easier to deal with this
has been nearly impossible for the
American people to deal with and it's
why you're seeing people sort of lashing
out you know you know kind of bashing
the bars of the cages that we've been
we've been put into and I think that it
can't last for much longer I think that
people are going to demand a solution I
think the solutions are forthcoming
people are discussing them I think that
eventually we're gonna end up with if
you're young and healthy you go back to
work I keep saying this I think there's
where we will be I think if you're older
and vulnerable you stay at home I think
that we don't do big mass events for a
while until there's a vet saying I think
that we reopen the schools and I think
that we go back to eating at restaurants
I think that movie theaters probably end
up with some sort of social distancing
there are certain industries they're
just not gonna come back the same way
but we are not all gonna stay home from
work for 12 or 18 months or three years
or something that's ridiculous
but yeah I mean in terms of is this
worse than 9/11 yeah it's way worse than
9/11 in terms of the impact on the
American people we were all in New
Yorkers on 9/11 we are all you know we
are all human beings when it comes to a
global pandemic alrighty well we'll
bring you all of your corona virus
updates also I'm off the next two days
so just a quick reminder I am off for
two days but then I will be back on
Friday you're listening to the Ben
Shapiro show